on en parle beaucoup dans les quatre
coins du monde sont menacées par la
sécheresse des sécheresses qui
pourraient même menacer la paix dans
certains pays alors pour mieux
comprendre ce matin l'impact de la
raréfaction de l'eau et des sécheresses
on reçoit deux invités monsieur hossein
bon akhdari vous êtes professeur agrégé
au département de génie civil de
l'université d'ottawa et carla une
brouille est vous êtes directrice des
politiques nationales du réseau action
climat canada bonjour et merci à vous
d'être là ce matin alors j'ai envie de
commencer par vous caroline la crise est
tellement importante à les global
partout aux etats-unis france chine inde
de la corne de l'afrique
c'est presque indéniable que les
changements climatiques sont au banc des
accusés maintenant qu'on a dit ça quel
rôle peuvent jouer les gouvernements
pour gérer ces crises
écoutez je ce matin en préparation
d'entrevue je suis aller relire le
rapport du giec sur les impacts pour
regarder ce que la science dit là dessus
et en fait on sait qu'avant points 5
degrés celsius de réchauffement
climatique on sait qu'aujourd'hui l'on
est à un point d'eux déjà
le risque de sécheresse dans le monde
vient doubler et ces événements leur
devienne non seulement plus fréquent
mais également plus intense donc la
première chose à faire en fait pour
réduire la tâche dans la tap
d'adaptation c'est d'atténuer nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre afin
de limiter le changement climatique sous
ce seuil critique de 20 points 5 degrés
celsius parce qu'au delà de ça mais on
s'expose aux effets elle est plus
intense les plus sévères des changements
climatiques comme les sécheresses mais
malheureusement ça ne se restreint pas à
ce titre d'événements climatiques
extrêmes alors ce sont quoi les
les actions concrètes que peuvent faire
les gouvernements parce que là la balle
est un peu dans leur camp nou la
population a beau recyclés et changer
son mode de transport ont fait de
petites choses mais ça prend pas à m'en
donner un grand coup de barre la sphère
des gouvernements surtout des grandes
puissances
tout à fait je voyais votre collègue
juste maintenant parler du plan de
réduction d'inflation l instruction
d'action des états unis c'est quand même
un plan historique la première fois en
trente ans que les états unis le
principal émetteur mondial
historiquement
réussi à adopter une législation sur les
changements climatiques donc c'est
significatif mais ce n'est pas suffisant
parce que notamment le plan continue de
promouvoir l'expansion de la production
des énergies fossiles et en fait c'est
un peu la même chose qu'on voit ici au
canada même si le canada en comparaison
dépenses - là travers le budget 2022 on
a un cadre réglementaire qui est en
développement ça va être important pour
le gouvernement de bouger rapidement et
ne pas laisser les industries
et la qualité de ses réglementations là
et de l'autre ou three main ça nous nous
envoie un signal qu'on doit donner un
coup de barre au niveau de
l'investissement donc on doit augmenter
la promenade proportion du financement
public pour répondre à la crise
climatique au canada et finalement on
doit cesser de toujours continuer
l'expansion de la production d'énergies
fossiles on sait que le chancelier
allemand chaude sera au canada dans les
prochaines semaines on entend peut-être
une entente le sur la liquéfaction de
gaz naturel sur la côte est est elle ce
genre de projet là alors qu'on voit des
impacts des changements climatiques
sévères partout dans le monde je pense
qu'il faut nommer les choses ça n'a pas
de bon sens de continuer à bercy
littéralement de l'huile sur le feu
ouais c'est un peu contradictoire
monsieur bonnac d'harry vous êtes un
spécialiste des on sait que la
croissance démographique
elle existe en aura de plus en plus
d'humains sur la planète
alors comment faire avec plus de
population on doit produire davantage de
nourriture qu'elles soient de la
production bovine est que ce soit de
l'agriculture comment faire pour
irriguer les terres agricoles et
produire plus de nourriture toujours
alors que les seuls on a discuté à
fonctionner dès maintenant
oui tout à fait comme on peut voir dans
donc dans ces années là on nous avons là
déficit d'eau et le problème avec la
production agricole et nourriture pour
répondre à cette question là où vous
savez nous on a besoin appelant très
importante pour l'afrique pour les
photos c'est à dire il faut passer par
exemple il faut changer haïti pour la
technologie il faut aller pour
utilisation optimale de l'eau pour la
production agricole ce qui pose problème
pour les fautes oursons qui vaut d'être
sourd qui va arriver c'est le manque de
l'eau surtout qu'on on peut voir par
exemple nos peurs pour cette année on
est expérience est en déficit d'eau très
important tant dans l'euro par exemple
environ 85 % inférieur de normal de nos
balles dans un mois juillet en france ça
veut dire pour pour nous au canada le
moment qu on a besoin de l'eau pour pour
faute ou en apport d'eau assez d'eau
pour faire agricole et c'est pour ça on
a besoin de changer un petit peu comme
on a discuté pour un petit peu adaptée
au jour ajout ce nom au changement
climatique surtout une adaptation
utilisation
changement adaptation on parle beaucoup
des nouvelles technologies pour nous
aider à y arriver mais l'on oublie cette
semaine que dans des hommes
technologique on pense à la silicon
valley qu'on pense à bangalore qu'on
pense à taïwan là aussi à des
sécheresses vraiment importante et ça
prend de l'eau très très peur pour faire
la production de ces puces électroniques
la production de ces matériaux qu'est ce
qu'on fait on est un peu dans un service
et on a besoin des technologies pour
avancer mais on n'y arrive pas
finalement ça
oui exactement faire le problème
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est quoi la
solution caroline
si je peux me permettre je pense en fait
que la solution malheureusement elle
n'est pas technologique mais elle est
plutôt systémique en fait on sait que le
tiers de la production mondiale de
nourriture destinée à la consommation
humaine elle est gaspillée donc l'enjeu
malgré la croissance de la population et
malgré ce titre de d'événements qui vont
devenir de plus en plus extrêmes ce
n'est pas de répondre par une nouvelle
technologie mais plutôt à penser nos
systèmes et s'assurer que le premier
objectif ça soit ans et de répondre aux
besoins de tous
la question du gaspillage alimentaire
qui est importante mais aussi nos types
d'agriculture est extrêmement extractif
l'agriculture industrielle
impose sur le sol vraiment un coût élevé
ce qui fait en sorte que le succès des
sièges plus rapidement il ya plusieurs
études qui démontrent que l'agriculture
où on transmet du du sol permet non
seulement le d'accumuler plus d'hommes
et de séquestrer du carbone va falloir
repenser notre façon de faire les choses
sans nécessairement à recourir à des
nouvelles technologies qui on a tendance
à penser von ernst oui mais miraculeux
il va lui lever des options plus
créatives justement le giec nous parlait
du fait qu'on doit revoir à la baisse en
fait avoir une forme de sobriété dans
notre mode de consommation
alors c'est peut-être ce que vous dites
monsieur bonnac dari est ce que il y
aura une guerre de l'or bleu quelque
part sur la planète on voit déjà que des
tensions dans certains coins vous pensez
que ça sera vrai un véritablement un
enjeu bientôt
voyez c'est juste que je dois ajouter
quelques petites phrases par rapport aux
technologiques et moi j'ai dit c'est que
la magie moi je voulais dire la nouvelle
technologie pour l'irrigation la
nouvelle technologie pour l'agriculture
ça veut dire une utilisation optimale de
l'eau parce que le consommation plus
importants pour l'eau dans le monde
c'est la partie agricole qui vont
produire à paris dans le nori tour et
c'est ce qu'ils ont par d'autres
l'écologie c'est plutôt tout pour la
partie de production pour utilisation en
utilisation optimale dolo voilà par
rapport aux loyers aux changements de
climatique c'est vrai c'est la réalité
comme
on sait très bien où les besoins des
plantes à longueur surtout
l'effet de sécheresse ça pour rester
pour longtemps par exemple moi je peux
vous assurer le modèle de changement
climatique montrent encore une vraie
expérience et la sécheresse très
importants en europe parce que les
modèles montrent une changement
climatique qui va bouger vers l'europe
pour produire les
sélections très sèche pour la venue dans
leur côté voyez tout ce qui se passe il
ya une petite question pour le monde qui
s'écoule l'eau il va où on peut dire
ibles nous avons petit changement par
exemple maintenant on voit le problème
des inondations en même temps que nous
avons inondations l'asie en même temps
que nous avons le problème de sécheresse
dans l'euro c'est ça l'effet des
changements et qui pourrait arriver dans
le faux turquie pour jouer sur
l'ensemble de la planète
caroline janvier tout demander votre
organisation est souvent dans les coop
je connais certains de vos collègues
notamment dans les coop on réclame
beaucoup une hausse du financement pour
les pays développés pour les pays en
développement de la part des pays
développés on octroie certaine somme et
on sait d'ores et déjà que les montants
sont vraiment trop trop bas est ce que
c'est le temps la part des pays
développés de vraiment investir les
sommes qui sont nécessaires pour aider
le reste de la planète à s'adapter
finalement sécheresse extrême
tout à fait en fait les non seulement
l'argent qu'on a promis aux pays du sud
c'est une promesse ans et qui au sein de
l'accord de paris en les pays s'engagent
la côte et à réduire leurs émissions
mais étant donné que les une équité dans
la responsabilité pour la crise
climatique les pays qui en sont le plus
responsables sont ceux qui ressentent
les moins inspirés fait donc on s'est
engagé à mettre de l'argent sur la table
pour les pays du sud on s'est donné le 6
200 milliards qui était un petit peu
aléatoires on ne toujours pas atteinte
et cet argent leur est allouée en plus
en proportion à l'atténuation des
changements climatiques qu'à
l'adaptation donc ça va être important
de revenir d'abord à augmenter les
montants pour qu'il soit suffisant et
répondre réellement aux besoins donc ça
va aller ou de l'ordre des 5 milliards
promis par les pays du nord mais
également de rééquilibrer la proportion
est cette année à la coop 26 est un
enjeu qui va être central c'est celui
des pertes et dommages c'est à dire que
au delà de l'atténuation et de la date
de l'adaptation il ya des impacts des
changements climatiques auxquels et qui
sont simplement des pertes je pense par
exemple à la destruction totale de la
communauté de l'étude en colombie
britannique
on appelle ça une perte de ranger les
pays du sud en ville davantage donc on
doit mettre sur pied un mécanisme qui va
venir financer ses pertes et dommages
heures c'est une question d'équité et de
justice climatique alors au cndd bonnac
d'arx est professeur agrégé au
département de génie civil de
l'université d'ottawa carlin brouillette
est directrice des politiques nationales
du réseau action climat canada mercier à
vous d'avoir été là ce matin avec nous à
voir merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit